[Music]
you made it weird with Pete Holmes
what's happening weirdos this is the
return of the very very funny Kurt
braunholler Brown ohler Braun ohler Kurt
bronneller he's hilarious he has a new
special out currently and for a limited
time on moment you need to go to
perfectly
stupid.com to check that out I've since
watched it since this recording it is
incredible you'll see there's a little
mix up at the beginning it's very funny
uh but you need to check this out and it
is on only uh for a limited time and
then it'll be on video on demand but go
to perfectly stupid.com to check it out
if you'd like to see me doing some stand
up I am currently on tour I'm going to
be in Chicago this weekend so if you're
watching this the week it comes out I'm
coming to Chicago to be at the Den
November 10th through 12th go to
petehomes.com for tickets after Chicago
I'll be in San Francisco Portland
Seattle Atlanta Charlotte and Washington
D.C hopefully going to be adding some
more dates as well because the tour has
been so fun I really love this new hour
and it's just been so great to be back
together again hopefully you can make it
to a show yeah let's leave that in uh
just go to petehomes.com to see if I am
coming to be near you hopefully you like
this podcast hopefully you want to
support this podcast the way to support
it we don't have a patreon or a donate
just try a product try a Pete's pick
some of the things that I use and
actually love like our friends at Blue
land who remind us that the holidays can
create even more waste than usual each
year Americans throw away 25 more trash
from Thanksgiving to New Year's but what
if we told you there was a way to get
all your holiday shopping done without
the guilty feeling over the waist that
typically comes with it well meet blue
land blue land is on a mission to
eliminate single-use plastic which is
horrible get rid of that single-use
plastic and they're doing it by
Reinventing cleaning Essentials to be
better for you and for the planet and
this holiday season blue is having its
best sale of the year so you can save
and shop sustainably for your friends
family and even yourself the idea is
simple grab one of the beautiful forever
bottles that they make fill it with warm
water drop in the tablet and get
cleaning this is the whole idea instead
of buying a new bottle every time let
Blue land sell you a forever bottle and
a refillable reusable tablet refills
start at 225 and you don't have to buy a
new plastic bottle every time you run
out which is amazing you can even set up
a subscription or buy in bulk so you
never run out of products that you use
the most from cleaning sprays to hand
soap to toilet cleaner and laundry
tablets all blue land products are made
with ingredients you can feel good about
try their clean Essentials kit which has
everything you need to get started in
signature scents such as Iris Agave
fresh lemon and Eucalyptus mint a
personal flave you commend Plus for a
limited time blue lands hand soap is
getting a festive upgrade with a
beautiful chocolate box in inspired gift
set with cozy scents like Evergreen
Winterberry and peppermint I wish my
last name was Winterberry and I was
British so if you want products that are
good for you good for the planet and
make you feel better about the plastic
problem which is a big concern obviously
for me with stuff that works works works
all of their stuff works incredible it
feels great to use and you feel great
for doing the right thing take advantage
of their best sale of the year go to
blueland.com
ymiw you don't want to miss this
ymiw that's blueland.com y m i w and
show your support of this show
secondly the holidays are officially
upon us and it's time to start
celebrating but I mean like actually
celebrating it's your holiday too so you
should be able to relax and do what you
love that means watching every single
seasonally themed rom-com like it does
for me in jail so be it do your thing
and holiday your way with our friends at
me undies it's the most wonderful time
of the year to try me undies because
they're currently offering a very merry
deal get 20 off your first purchase with
free shipping uh with free standard
shipping and free returns when you go to
meandies.com let me see what I got today
dinosaurs Leela loves these I'm wearing
my dinosaur me undies I heard about me
undies on another podcast that I'm a fan
of years ago Val and I did a top to
Tails overhaul of our underwear our
loungewear PJ pants onesies all of that
stuff because they're micro modal fabric
is incredibly soft they fit great and
they have amazing prints so get your
holiday shopping finished early this
year and start making time for yourself
with the new me undies holiday
collection they're undies loungewear and
sleepwear are made out of the softest
most Supple fabric you've ever felt and
are guaranteed to bring comfort and joy
to your loved ones shop their classic
plaid prints for a traditional
picture-perfect style or get festive
with their adventurous limited edition
sweater prints that's the one I go with
available in size is extra small through
4XL me undies has what you need to make
all your favorite people smile this
holiday season all in one convenient
place and feel free to start thinking
about yourself now
they they I'm part of their subscription
so I get new me on these I don't know
what they've done recently but they're
even more comfortable for the past year
or so they re reinvigorated the whole
thing and I love them even more so to
get 20 off your first order free
shipping and 100 satisfaction guarantee
Go to meandies.com weird that's
meandies.com weird and show your support
of this show last but not least our
friends from ritual ritual has
completely revitalized and reinvented
what how I think about vitamins and
probiotics and has changed my life so
much for the better it's literally my
ritual and always makes me feel ready to
start my day I'm so happy when I go to
the doctor and they tell me that my
vitamins are all where they need to be
which is can be tricky especially uh if
you're like me and are mostly vegan but
here I'm going to talk about their new
synbiotic plus which is a pre-pro and
post-biotic all in one place so we're
talking about gut health and they're not
all the same let me ask you does your
probiotic contain clinically studied
strains well meet one that does rituals
symbiotic plus contains two of the
world's most studied strains with over
350 publications of human clinical
trials gut health comes up a lot
especially on the we made it weird
episodes It's like a second brain it's
the central well it's not literally your
central nervous system but it's like the
Grand Central Station of your body is
your gut and our food these days is just
not cutting it so you have to supplement
and I have tried a lot of different
kinds and let me tell you ritual
symbiotic plus ticks all of the boxes
what makes the their components so
clearly ritual well they're science
backed and research stacked especially
when stacked up against the leading
directors consumer and top selling
probiotics on the market it's more than
a probiotics it's three in one with
clinically studied prebiotics which is
like the food for probiotics probiotics
and a postbiotic to support a balanced
gut microbiome single nested it means
it's one pill wrapped in a minty capsule
there's not a bad taste in fact there is
a good taste you open the bottle it
smells like mint you put in your mouth
tastes like mint and you are getting
streamlined gut support from a wonderful
daily simple minty capsule designed to
thrive in your colon not your stomach
there's a delayed release which is the
ideal place for probiotics to survive
and grow and best of all you do not need
to refrigerate them you can keep them
right in your cupboard so symbiotic and
ritual are here to celebrate not hide
your insides there's no more shame in
your gut game to make something to make
trying something new easier ritual is
offering weirdos 10 off for their first
three months when you shop online at
ritual.com weird prefer to shop in
person ritual is now available at Whole
Foods Market or go to ritual.com
weird get your uh what is it I want to I
just set it 10 off for the first three
months and show your support of this
show all right everybody be sure to go
to perfectly stupid.com to watch Kurt's
News special hope to see you on the road
hope to see you in Chicago this weekend
in the meantime enjoy my chat with the
hilarious Kurt Brown all our
crib Ronald get in Tropics like Lion's
man okay help you think a little bit of
tiny bit of caffeine like a cup of green
tea okay and a little honey and it makes
me feel fantastic amen
we should have cheered
cheers the empties
[Laughter]
yeah
interested in that as a um
stand-up writer
nothing better for real I mean
they do sponsor the Pod but it went like
this I discovered it yeah I reached out
to them but like oh really before I do
shows
it's like um because for me I just
listened to your special by the way and
it's phenomenal I say listen because on
the drive down yeah I had it on
Paramount plus oh nice not watching the
video but just like audio coming through
the car and I was I was howling man it's
fantastic Paramount plus that's how I
found it did you watch the you watch the
2017 one what do you mean you want to
trust me that's not the new one no I
don't know
their new special yeah yeah and it and
that's what came up yeah yeah you
watched the old one I'm [__] kidding
me I love that you watched the old one
though this is the old humiliation no no
I knew oh Curtis that's okay I want you
to feel welcome and celebrated and I was
like you just listened to an hour of me
doing Santa comedy I feel welcome okay
good you know okay as long as you don't
feel like what the [__] is this because
I was like I'm gonna do it the morning
yeah yeah so I can gush about it yeah
yeah and I watched the old one yeah you
watch the one yeah I mean it's on it was
well I'll tell you this it ends with the
beaver joke yes nothing made me more
excited to see more of your content I
should have known because you were like
I've only been married two years I
remember being like this isn't weird
and no baby material yeah no baby yeah
the new hour is all about being a dad
[__] man which is right up my alley yeah
we can but now it's all we can just talk
about being pads that's true yeah and
I'm excited about that but I will watch
it before I do the intro and I'll talk
earnestly about the intro I I don't know
I'm not this isn't coming from a place
of uh defense I'm not like I'm so sorry
but like I want to promote it yeah also
tell me about how you put it out because
somebody somebody told me it's kind of
this thing [__] get it get it down
get it down trying to get in between us
just like make a gif out of this
JK not a good game when would you send
that gift so it is on moment and so it
lives yeah works there and so it lives
there for three weeks
and you can go and watch them so many
times yeah moment three moments three
moments
a moment is actually 12 quivies yeah
yeah so quippy was
three eighths of a day it was like half
a CSO
well have a CSO 12 quilt these are three
moments
so it's like you just pay 10 bucks you
get to watch it for those three weeks
and then it disappears off of there and
then you own it again yeah and then it
eventually it will go up on like Amazon
and VOD for about a month and then it's
part of a Amazon company uh it'll be on
just video on demand sites so like all
of them yeah
uh I guess you own it yeah yeah do you
really own anything nothing it's that
kind of podcast is it can you no
I do want to say even though I listen to
the wrong one you you got all my sillies
going oh thank you it's a good special
silly it's a silly special but just
we're going to get back to a moment I
won't forget
but you're a silly performer and and I'm
a silly beans yeah and and like watching
someone do it so well I know it's the
old one but um it's just like it
reminded me you remind me as a performer
of what I love about stamina oh thank
you it's like shockingly dirty things
out of nowhere and like very silly
things it's all out of nowhere but like
that that's what you choose to do with
your time up there and I have to assume
in the new one it's the same same kind
of same kind of guy yeah yeah same kind
of guy yeah yeah it does have a the new
one I think has an emotional core to it
that the old one doesn't like exactly
it's not an emotional nugget right in
the middle look it is an emotion what is
nougat no good it's got to be emotional
first of all I say nougat you say nougat
I say nougat I just realized that I say
nuggets that must be Jersey what is JJ
abrams's production company I don't even
know oh you don't um what is it called
what is the Jetsons made what is she oh
uh oh man Nelly no no no not her name
not her name just like fundamental a
robot don't say robit because I feel
like no get what are you saying nougat
no say it again no good no good yeah
what is it called when you knuckle
someone's hair a noogie and then the
core of a sticker of a Milky Way it's
nugget yeah Katie
nugen nougat what is the uh
controversial musician Ted no no no no
you you must say nudgeon Nugent
I say it I'm a very European Union
and nugget it does if you were the
foreign exchange student that you look
like you would go like I love the Milky
Way it comes with the Nugget I can't
even say it wrong no I love the nougat
nougat nugget nugget I think it's Jersey
honestly it could be I have OU stuff
that comes out and I don't expect it the
OU's yeah the umlooded I was just trying
to learn I haven't
I have an audition later today nice for
those listening to the audio and not
watching the video first of all shame on
you second JK secondly I just dropped my
mic uh and I was trying to learn a
Pittsburgh accent and all about what
they do with the OU's apparently those
are that's tough man you know what I'm
gonna say at the top of the uh Oddish
yeah you ready for this yeah I'm ready I
want to know if you respect the game or
if you don't like people back it up a
little bit yeah yeah hey guys if you
give me the part I'll get the accent
right I love that like what am I gonna
devote seven hard ones yeah to div like
and then just blow the idea and then now
I just because also what do they want do
they want a funny person who can act or
do they want someone who can nail a
Pittsburgh accent you have peeled there
were two pages of a very thin
encyclopedia and and you peel them
together and everything you needed to
know about comedians acting auditioning
was on those pages and we just
discovered them there's like a
and there it was yeah and Mr Bean is
also there okay um go on you have a
Jersey accent you say nugget no no yeah
and I'm trying to remember where else it
comes out I know it comes out in
something like oh it's the always voice
I I I hear myself saying it to my my
kids and I'm like oh they're gonna
they're gonna pick this up and I think I
should correct it but I don't know no
interest not doing it oh with Shauna I
say Shauna Shauna yeah instead of Sean
Shauna Shauna yeah is that a name Shawna
Shawna yeah yeah but that's that Au that
Au sound and where it appears in seven
places is it a name
Shauna have you never heard that I've
heard of Chandra
okay I have as well
where how old are you when you realize
because for me it was it's like a Trope
but for me it was very recently that
girl traditional speaking gender
normatively girl names have boy versions
like you know what I'm saying uh yeah uh
like France
Brianna like Brianna was just like a
stubborn guy who wanted a Brian and he
was like uh Brianna that's a good bet
but there there's
first of all as someone who's thirsty
for bits like for real I know oh yeah I
know I I just released a new hour I'm
thirsty for a bit can you also tell me
uh I will write that down but can you
tell me now that I have children and
we're we're getting we're getting right
into that carpool lane just get in the
carpool lane it's where we belong I
sometimes do it and I would tell if they
pulled me over I would say I have kids
they're not in the car right now but I
have kids I've heard people use the
excuse I thought my baby was in the car
seat
I'm such a good dad I always have my kid
in the car right and and it's even
buckled even though they're not in it
yeah yeah did you notice that I Buckle
air I I Buckle onions a bundle of onions
are buckled in my car seat that's like I
was warming up for an impromptu a bundle
of bunions is buckled in my car seat
um I couldn't even say it let's get in
the carpool lane and talk about kids now
that I have kids
I I do find I have to be a little bit
more effortful coming up with jokes
meaning My pre-kid Lifestyle was just
this this is my pre-kid lifestyle we're
hanging out we're farting around and
every once in a while I go have you
noticed that names have boy versions of
girl versions you say that's a bet now
that 99 and I prefer this a million I
actually think it's the opposite of
crazy making it's sane making yeah
having something that you care about
things that you would love to hear your
thoughts on that but I also find that
like I don't
I don't have as many bits coming in and
I have to set side set time aside to be
like I guess I'll think of a bit now or
whatever which I never used to do and I
didn't even notice until I went back out
on the road and like almost the moment I
got on the plane by myself I would be
like that's a bit like a thought that I
had like that's a bit because you're not
just you know and I was like oh [__]
it's that's what my life used to be but
now my life is always just like you
gotta get the kid to the thing and then
go and then make sure that and then
everybody's got to eat everyone's hasn't
eaten yet you know it's just like who's
peed and who's pee you have three
letters you're in charge of we just did
like is there a greater nightmare than I
put Leela down and you go did she pee
and you're like she didn't pee and now
I'm putting a diaper on a sleeping baby
and I'm like half as like the whole
rigmarole yeah go on we just do we're
just doing potty training on my youngest
old PT man and you know what the best PT
is I want to interrupt right now what no
pants yeah no pants yeah we did no pants
let them go nude yeah he did [__] on the
floor once I mean it's fun
yeah the floors there they're so close
that also they are they're very close
and also the fact that it happens like
almost the way like uh like an alpaca
shits like where he's just like walking
and then shits and then doesn't realize
he's done it and it's like really that's
fascinating there's no like little
petals or anything it's just like little
Eminem I'm just standing I know they are
Perfection and they show you what
pooping could and should be yeah and
it's not any longer my it's like a buck
shot now
why is why is it occurring like this and
I look at Leela and what she and they
really can't eat anything I I had a
little of Leela's Halloween candy uh
don't tell her she doesn't watch
she's a Conan needs a friend girl
but I ate some of her candy heartburn
couldn't sleep like like I ate like an
Almond Joy like at 11 o'clock and I was
like more like I'm in agony am I right
this is what I mean the bits they come
back
they'll become more labored I can't do
them anymore so you're pting uh yeah
we're beating and so yeah that whole
idea of just like oh man and also not
stressing them out where it's I've
noticed that's the thing that I've just
recently noticed how quickly I go to
like
in my head of like I can't deal with
this anymore you know and I have to just
constantly when you stress them out with
your stress when yeah and I'm trying not
to stress them out I say that to Lilo
all the time I go like Lila you're
stressing me like I try to just yeah
that's my strategy I don't I don't know
if it's right yeah or good or wrong
right now but I I would have let's just
say I'm being the parent that is a exact
response to the parents I had meaning
for better or worse I personally would
have loved it if my dad or my mom was
just like if my mom was like you're I'm
really stressed out right now I'm like
this is freaking me out yeah I don't
know what to do but if you hear my voice
it's because I'm I'm like panicking I
you know a little bit not in a situation
where you need to be like strong or
Brave or have resolved it doesn't mean
like she's been crying and I'm like
Leela like I hear it and then I go I'm
stressed out and like sometimes she'll
go like I'm sorry I stressed you out
like after the storm and I'm like this
is the best relationship
it's pretty great so it's Leela said oh
sorry no we're just two dads talking
yeah I picked her up from school the
other day and she went how was your day
first how was your day for life that's
crazy how old she's 14. I'm just getting
cheese for when will that not be funny
it's always funny to get it wrong but
she's four she just turned four okay
that's great I melted like an m m in the
car yeah it was I was completely gone
Mike neither of my kids have ever asked
me how my day was that is they could not
give a [__] it's Golden Girls they don't
get well she didn't want this is the
question it's like it's like what's next
what snack do I got today it's just like
Jesus you're an assistant we gotta dial
this back you're an assistant yeah an
exec you're not even an executive
assistant yeah yeah executive assistant
excuse me uh Kurt uh yeah were the
snacks here yeah that's right that would
be the executive assistant way but you
do find that there's a humbling that is
good well yeah talk about it tell me
about it because I could go on and on
but I I want this to be the Kurt Braun
ho older experience I think that it's
just yeah I mean like once you have a
kid I think and then my buddy Matt
Donnie told me this once he's like once
you have a kid you realize this is like
parents and there's kids in the world
the whole world is broken down to
parents and kids and meaning the people
that don't have kids just remain not
Katie it's not true it's not true it's
not true this isn't true that's not true
of Katie not true Katie dog parent dog
parent yeah yeah okay I'll give one
eighth of a cup
before baby that was not prep that was
not prep at all oh yeah yeah you leave
all day and you just leave it in the
[__] joke that I saw of yours
recently that I love so much tell me of
the like is like I know what like we're
the same species my dog I have no yes
they're just like my never-ending eye
contact yeah
do you know I wanted to tell you about
this that I think eye contact from a dog
is the dog tried to dominate you that is
Is that real I turned to Katie is it is
it like eye contact because I know I I
think like I because my dog always makes
eye contact with me and I'm like oh he's
trying to be you run you run you think
you run this house
whereas there apparently with the the
whatever dog the Alpha Dog which has
been debunked uh what do you mean the
alpha dog's been debunked this is
fascinating oh let's get into this kick
this down I want to talk about this
Google this right now will get the heart
details that dog has been debunked by
the person who invented alpha dog so it
was a guy who followed a pack of wolves
around the quarterback at my high school
yeah Johnny Johnny
he said that was a bunch of [__] and
then he threw a spiral perfect some way
we think it's true Johnny he threw it at
the sun and it was so hard and so far
that after 28 minutes we heard a small
Sizzle he hit the Sun and made sound
travel through a vacuum
good folks actually what we were hearing
was someone else who threw a fall of the
sun seven years earlier
long it takes it's not seven years oh
what for life for light to get eight
minutes eight minutes okay all right
um I got it seven years
I thought if the sun burned out would
would still have good light for seven
years
buddy but think about those eight
minutes think about those eight minutes
right when the sun burns out and then
there's eight minutes where everything's
fine yeah and you just listen to Carly
Simon yeah you don't know what you got
to list on and then it just Fades out
that'll be that's scary so Alpha Dog
yeah so the guy he followed around this
pack of wolves and he noticed that there
was this one wolf a male wolf that
everyone deferred to this is when he
made up the theory right yeah and so
then he wrote this book and I think the
book is called alpha dog
the next year when he went back to study
the same wolf pack he figured it out
that it wasn't they're not just
unrelated individuals that that was the
dad
so it was a family structure and it's
not a social structure and there is no
social Alpha Dog in a wolf pack it's
always familial and oftentimes it's a
female
um and so like
sometimes
and then just no one read it no one read
it people were like Alpha Dog we alpha
dog took off like he was on TV shows
immediately yes people were like yes we
this alpha dog thing we're behind and
then he came out the next year one year
later and was like guys it's wrong it's
wrong Alpha dog's not a thing and people
were like [__] off it's a thing the man
who made Alpha Dog
and it's been like his like commute is
going
thank you so much the guy who told us
the true thing
that justifies you getting beat up by
the quarter and being an [__] of a
boss cause you have to be like a wolf
for some reason
I'm a chiminal he's screaming I didn't
do it I didn't feed the mic up just for
him to say my name's not Jim it's Jim
it's Jim jiminer my whole life I've been
called Jim uh isn't that fascinating it
is fascinating but immediately I go to
can we get a structure of wolves that
aren't related and see what happens I
don't know
first one's called Alpha Dog second
one's called whoops no Alpha third
double whoops should have found a group
of non-related dogs no the third one's
called get these dogs together yeah who
who indeed let the dogs yeah I'd like to
know that guy devoted his life to
knowing who let the dogs out yeah for
real because who led them who led the
dogs out what about a flocking oh no
geese are always flopping there's a
leader and then they're like like a
Peloton like a what is that in biking
terms right there's like uh they all
line up and then they switch leader
position to draft everybody and I think
that's what geese do too oh we got it
from the geese yeah I also found out
that when we get goose down it's a
horrible brutal process do they do it
alive Jason Alexander we were talking
yeah when he did we were talking about
it and somebody from Peter emailed me
and was like look I'm not trying to bum
you out but just because you asked which
I get a lot of emails like that you're a
pod man yeah they're actually really
helpful yeah we also here's another one
I got recently that's a brutal and
horrible process no surprise there yeah
I don't know who I was thinking it's
some like King being like Oh one feather
or them shaking them off that's ideal
into a coat and they follow the shape of
the code and they're like extra large
it's
horrible the other one was we don't
leave fighter jets running all day some
have you heard that it's I guess it's an
urban map no because somebody in the Air
Force was like that's not true please
tell people that's not true because it
was one of those things about like how
grotesque and Hyper masculine the
military that they don't want the to
waste the three seconds to fire let's
say it's five minutes or it might be 90
seconds to fire up a fighter jet so they
just leave it running all day and I was
like that is like the most America this
is uh America's Funniest Home Videos by
the way America this is you is that
actually the song they use now you don't
remember that no that's from the 90s
stories from your friends next door they
never told you might be star tonight so
let that camera roll your red white and
blue all the funny things you do America
I really thought you might join me this
is I don't know it at all you didn't
watch America's Funniest Home Videos I
did I don't think I watched the credits
I don't think credits you had him on
mute yeah but they had it would just it
would just become a killer Clips in the
intro there's guys it's what you tuned
in for there's a guy falling on a banana
peel what who would have who would have
guessed America's Funniest Home Videos
that that would just be the future of
the internet like that that is the
internet that is exactly what everything
was here here's one one billionth of the
internet yeah and if you had told Little
Pete and little Kurt in the future that
one video that you really liked for some
reason it's filled with imagery you
don't even understand psychologically
why you love it a guy in an old wig like
a like a judge's Parliament wig falling
off a diving board into an empty pool if
you like that you can find thousands of
that it's all the time it's like porn we
did a monologue on
if you liked big asses like for most of
human history you were just out of luck
you were just like they were just so
there were only like 70 people in your
little tribe and you'd just be like oh
not not a not a pumpkin amongst them
and now you can uh you know find a big
ass yeah
sorry I'm gonna be coughing my speaking
of babies my baby keeps bringing home a
fresh a fresh cold oh yes as soon as
we're over beautiful she brings us home
a new one it's beautiful it's just none
is it for you as well oh yeah and Lauren
five straight years constant colds
constant colds I think at this I mean
like yeah I'm luckily in between that's
all that's the best you can hope for
that's the best you could and I just I
just was uh shooting something and I
wanted to be like I'm in I'm in a
Avalanche of mucus like not even
literally just how I feel I feel like
slimed and slow and today this energy
you're getting today is like me starting
to come out of it oh nice even knowing
I'm 11 days away right from the next one
right in my face yeah and I'm back in it
fascinating how often they get sneezes
to the back of your throat oh that's how
that's fascinating to me I was like it's
so perfect it's like not intentional but
perfect aimed right to the back of my
throat and sometimes tonsils I'll pick
Leela up and I'll see a kid sneeze in
her face and I'm just like this is
this is how it happens yeah my daughter
also Wolverine to someone who took her
marker the other day and she just
splashed their face
have you experienced the weird feeling
of like first of all obviously 99.9
that's horrible we have to talk about
that and then you're kind of like
you can't help but side with your kid
does that make sense I'm even hesitant
to say this I don't want to publicly
there's no part of me this is glad that
happened we talked to her about it it
can't happen again we cut her nails too
and then like let's let's remove the uh
the X factories mittens she now wears
mittens Mike birbiglia's sleeping bag
style but I constantly like no matter
what Leela does outside with her have
you experienced this phenomena I almost
I think I go uh not well to the other
side of it where I'm like too quick to
be like don't you even I can't believe
you you know really I do it like almost
unconsciously and then I have to pull
myself back you're that that's the style
dad you're yeah by the way neither of
these are right I'm just saying exactly
to be the dad that like Val will go you
can't even see Leela's Behavior yeah I
just see a perfect beam of Heaven's
light yeah no matter what she's doing so
if she slashes the face I'm like that's
what the Lord decreed today yeah I think
I do this is what that kid deserves this
is how life is and that boy needed to
learn he needed a lesson and the Lord's
hand came down and my daughter's head to
teach him that lesson today and she
doesn't I go thus saith that scratcheth
the Lord is what I say I don't know I
feel more uh I think it's embarrassment
that's what it is that I immediately
feel like deeply embarrassed that it
reflects on you or yeah that it reflects
on and it doesn't it does not reflect on
me it's a child I wouldn't say it does
sort of it does sort of but it shouldn't
because right oh no exactly in fact
every almost everything we're going to
be saying today it's not how it should
be yeah but like sometimes you do catch
yourself like you there's the kid that
like Hucks a spear and kills a cat and
you're like
yeah it's probably something at home
even though it's stolen
I know it but it is it but you don't
know
see you just did it oh my God Spears are
they letting the Kid kill the chicken
for dinner we had kids we had like we
had like a rash of like older boys that
my that my daughter that is what a group
of older boys is called by the way are
right A Murder of crow is a rack for
boys
who always were just like she just
looked up to them and they're bullies
you know and it was how old is she now
she's five now five and a half and
luckily she's out of that a situation
that has that and the rash uh the rash
there's no rash there's rashes around
but she's part of a yeah there's pox's
yeah there's rashes
um she's part of a crew now that I think
is she's happy with but
um and it was I it always like would go
back to in my head just being like
those parents are probably [__] up
buddy well it's because you know
honestly there's a there's a good way to
do it
there's a there's it's so close to a
good way to do it meaning if someone
cuts you off in traffic you can walk it
back and be like there's a way that
they're not really culpable like no
one's really guilty of anything which
isn't really satisfying at all at all we
hate this yeah our whole society is
built on like that's not true but there
is a way to find compassion where you're
like I I think it was Rupert spiral was
like your parents are behaving exactly
as people would act if they had the
parents they had right and that opens up
compassion you just go like in the same
but we don't like it would rather be
like yeah well snap out of it you know
like snap out of it and make a new way
have you noticed yourself because I've
noticed this in myself that you've
become more empathetic towards adults
bad behavior because of your children
like in the level of tiredness for sure
yeah or yeah just being like if someone
cuts you off just being like looks like
somebody maybe didn't have a snack today
or like looks like somebody didn't sleep
well last night because it's like my bed
every it's the same needs it's the same
needs and when my kids are acting like
[__] I'm like why are they acting
like [__] I was like they didn't
sleep last night or they're hungry and
the worst thing about uh not the worst
thing but like a bad thing about kids is
that they can't tell you yeah and you
know what my parents are the same way I
don't think my parents know what
dehydrated feels like right I'd say that
to their face and I think I was like
that until I had kids where if I was
hungry I would just be an [__] and
like my wife yeah [__] eat something
you're a piece of [__] right now that it
eats and be like I'm sorry I bet a piece
of [__] parents are reverse Gremlins you
have to feed them after a minute like
you have to constantly feed them and
they visited recently they don't turn
into monsters if you feed them yeah
exactly and they should my mom came it
was one o'clock Kurt these [__]
have been up since six it's 1 p.m yeah
first thing my dad's and when they left
the day before I was like Dad make sure
Mommy make sure Mom eats because it's a
it's it's just off the rails bad yeah
when when no one eats first thing he
says is
she hasn't eaten and I I like another
internet meme I just went you had one
job because it was just like you brought
I don't know what it's like you gave a
like a a shark that's been given blood
like it's like a terrible terrible
situation eat yeah or you have to just
it's like almost that you have to just
travel with like knishes at all times
and just like give honestly yeah which
is what I do as a parent yeah which is
what I have to do with my parents yeah
exactly preparing your parents one
thing's become apparent if you're a
parent you still haven't preparing your
parents I am actually dealing with one
two three four bladders my own my
parents and my daughters so okay you
just did this you were telling me about
the structure it's on is it on moment
currently yes so it's on moment right
now it'll be there doing well November
16th I know that's good I don't know I
don't know yet okay
um the response has been really great
yeah and I saw the New York Times thing
yeah I've been trying to get it the New
York Times to review anything I've done
for 15 years and it was finally like oh
that's so nice I used to be so nice I
thought they reviewed everything I know
I put my book out I was like I can't
wait to see the New York Times book
review and it's like that's a huge piece
of publicity even if it's an review it's
still millions of people we'll see it
like you don't you don't just get that
someone vied for that yeah so they
reviewed it which is awesome which is
awesome that's cool and so I have no
idea and then I'm only asking I wasn't
sniffing around your butt it's more like
should I do this like I'm about to do a
special I think what's nice about it is
that it allows a way to just get it
directly to fans you know they don't
have to pay for any other services they
don't have to be a member of anything
thank you why not do Louis CK
complications noted uh why not do just
put it on your website uh yeah that is
like the what's nice about moment is
that you can do like bundles of like
meet and greets and After parties that
they facilitate with their software and
so it's like with the everybody watches
it at a specific time so having the
specific time as the premiere you get
like just a big bike in ticket sales for
everyone to watch it kind of together
and then you're there and then you do
like kind of an after party that's
online as well uh that's fun yeah so
that's the reason I think for a moment
as opposed to just on a website did they
pay for the production of it uh there
was 800 pound gorilla the production
company yeah
and point gray where the production
company but that means they fronted the
money yeah okay because it's expensive
to shoot a special yeah I mean all this
inside baseball is I'm like now it used
to be you'd get a fee in the end they'd
make it yeah and now it's like they'll
give you a fee and you have to make it
and the fee covers making it and then
you're like well I guess I don't have to
be wearing clothes and I don't have to
be lit and then I can go home with 600
just a candle yeah yeah these used to be
sweet little paydays they did and now uh
just like four or five years four or
five years ago what everything it like
remember it's like Chappelle and and and
the mullaney's all sort of skin the
goose but we skinned it once yeah that's
what's weird is that like why can't the
goose grow some more skin yeah
did it not work
it's not it's supposed to be shaved the
Sheep yeah sheer the Sheep they they
slaughtered the Sheep instead of
shearing this yeah the Jeep is dead the
ship's long dead and Chappelle running
away Chappelle has the code they gave me
yes he's wearing the 30 million dollar
code the 30 I don't million but I mean
remember yes of course you do when
streamings came out it was like
everybody's getting five million
messages
it was like um Super Deluxe remember
Super Deluxe of course I do but both
iterations when I don't remember two
iterations of Super Deluxe oh my god
there was the 2005 iteration of Super
Deluxe
Penelope princess of pets and then they
came back they came back they came back
in like 2015 or 2016 or something and
they were around for like four years and
then closed again I just have to say and
I'd love for you to weigh in on this uh
having done Showbiz having done been in
Show Business for 20 years having done
show business with nougat uh I've
noticed that if something flares up
really bright it could be a club it
could be a channel it's going away and
it's giving everyone yeah great
treatment and everybody loves it you get
ten thousand dollars just to take the
meeting yeah thank you don't forget your
ten thousand dollar gift bag that thing
is [__] gone it's like a beautiful
unicorn that isn't long for the workout
again early run in now and leave it's
like the Maui Comedy Festival was that a
thing it was a king for one year it was
amazing I bet it was they took a
snorkeling we went out on a sailboat we
did shows we stayed at a beautiful hotel
and then
it's completely gone it's also uh Comics
which we both worked in in New York yes
you get one entree one appetizer and as
many limited edition
Top Shot and I was like we were all like
28 years we're like yeah I'm going to do
my yeah and then you go to the club
that's been open for 50 years and
they're like you get half off tonic
water and you're like what right but you
realize there's a certain degree you
have to treat us like the animals we are
yeah we will destroy it could we have
taken that 30 mil that Chappelle got and
just and just saved five of those men
five mil that would be I can't do the
math I'm not here to do math I'm here to
have fun with you but I'm gonna say it
takes seven years for life to reach the
Earth from the sun I'm gonna say at
least 700 specials can come from that
five million right and we'd all like the
old days like the like the you know like
the 30 grand 50 Grand specials and
you're still like that's a that's a
that's teacher's salary in a day and
everybody's happy and now it's like no
you can you you will host it yeah but
that's just that's just space on your
server I will host on my computer too
yeah you I'm hosting it
I'm doing the bets okay so I'm glad this
exists because there needs to uh there
needs to be a new way yeah yeah so it's
just there for a limited amount of time
then it'll go TV on TV on demand and
then eventually it'll end up on YouTube
yeah so that people will actually see it
which is so different from you know Mike
my that hour that you watched on
Paramount plus it just recently became
available stop stop bringing that up the
hour that you wrongly watch I mean like
when it came out in 2017 it aired at
midnight you also talked about the movie
uh avalanche Everest
and that was old then and it was all
them and the joke was that it was old
and I was like I don't remember the
movie ever
he's talking about the gray I mean he
didn't talk about the gray but people
get so upset about that joke online the
Everest the Everest joke they get so mad
and then and this was the they always
call me uh they're like a soy boy and I
was like I didn't even know soy boy was
still an insult and then Low T this
guy's Low T because I don't because I
think it's stupid for people to climb
Everest okay let's go with that premise
yeah yeah because I've been thinking
about this a lot
testosterone okay we are our hormones
I'm gonna keep this real quick poor
Katie hears me say we are our hormones
all the time we are basically a block of
tofu and our hormones pass through this
yes and and we respond accordingly and
if you have low T and they're right
climbing a mountain makes less sense
it's true that is facts yeah if you have
high tea now we're just talking about a
higher concentration of a hormone yeah
passing through your central nervous
system climbing a mountain makes sense
yeah can't we just agree then that our
hormones low or high are just kind of
making us insane like you do this a lot
yeah increases testosterone you're more
likely to fight someone because you have
higher testosterone yeah isn't that like
meaning you're more aggressive yeah I've
talked about this ad nauseam I'm going
to put it back to you it's like I
started lifting weights for the first
time in my life I'm 43 years old and I
was like I can't believe people aren't
talking about this I started lifting
weights and I'm talking about like two
weeks of consistent weight training in I
noticed my personality was fundamentally
different really fundamentally different
meaning That's how little testosterone
maybe I had before I don't know if I was
low T every time I went to the doctor
they were like it's in the normal range
so it wasn't low but now I'm spiking it
and I'm getting all this like blood flow
and testosterone yeah and like in the
car way less patient uh I noticed
getting angry way faster and I
understand people are saying perhaps or
thinking perhaps that's a placebo I
don't know if there's a more highly a
finely tuned instrument for noticing how
I feel and what's different than myself
meaning that happens to be one of my
greatest passions as a stand-up that's
where it kind of started it's like I had
a great show I had dinner 90 minutes
before like I've always looked at my own
life as a science experiment so there
were no others right yeah and just like
yeah people always call like Scotty my
co-host on bananas always calls me like
like the old the old the old science kit
because I'm just like I will have two
shots of espresso at this time before my
show here and then I will eat after yeah
like I always want to know what other
people's thinking yeah yeah somebody was
taking a B12 before their show and I was
like what's that Baraka that's what I'm
into what's Baraka Barack is from
Australia
what is he Hawking now other than
[Laughter]
b rock a
b-e-r-o-c-ca it's [__] awesome okay
it's a vitamin B it's a fizzy thing you
drop it in vitamin B A little bit of
caffeine a little bit of guarinar and it
is
okay the [__] yeah are you feeling that
magic mind at all are you feeling happy
feeling I am right 100 okay one for one
I uh okay will you write that down and
remind me Baraka from Mortal Kombat 2.
he wasn't in one anyone going around
saying he was in one
I'm just kidding I'm tired like that's
that was just absolute nothing
we found absolute nothing uh you're a
science experiment yes and have you
because I I remember you you you are why
I intermittent fast I still do oh yeah
I've intermittent fasted for coming up
about six years because you told me at
kumail's house you looked great I guess
this is now you this is the you I've
saved yeah yeah but there was a softer
Curt I think because I saw you and I was
like what the [__] yeah and I consider
you another me out there like tall white
comedian similar we get ready all that
stuff and I was like well then I'll just
do that
um so is that is that still happening
and also what are the other experiments
you're running on I had not been doing
that but then
um just like General laziness and then I
have The Tonight Show in two days so I
was just like I want to drop a couple
pounds before I do The Tonight Show and
so I just started doing it again and uh
yeah that's you really feel it then
like if you like fast for 2 24 hours and
then you're just like well now I will
have this avocado and then you're just
like
avocado power it's so weird I completely
agree I I'm embarrassed that I brought
it up if Val were here she would be like
oh boy it's one of my topics don't get
me started don't get me start on cold
exposure or fasting but really it's not
even about meaning the way it makes you
look is is lower on the list for me it
gets you incredibly high in fact
everything that I'm into is about
getting really really hot do you still
use those nicotine uh tooth that was a
that was a long that was a probably a
two-year experiment with nicotine really
glad you brought that up loved nicotine
but recognize what addiction is that
that actually helped me learn what
addiction is and it's actually way worse
than I thought it was nicotine is it is
it's the top one I mean like Doug
Stanhope has a bit about it where he had
and it's in I think it's in his special
beer hall pitch but he talks about like
his neighbor who he lived next to was a
boxer who had been like just beat in the
head so many times that he was like just
like had so much brain damage but then
as soon as they he came over to watch a
show or something as soon as Doug lit a
cigarette up he's like oh
oh like the nicotine thing just wraps
itself around the like that remained
that remained the desire to have a
cigarette everything was damaged yes but
it's so crazy but this is what's
important this is what was important for
me I can't know other people's
experiences I just can't yeah the guy
who takes things way too serious I just
can't no I can't know all right if you
want me to know I know I can't help you
okay that's exactly what I was going for
um I thought addiction meant this [__]
is awesome like of course you want more
nicotine it makes you feel incredible
right and nicotine does tickle out of
the box so that that old homes he is
looking for me too energy uh mood
elevation and it's a neurotropic meaning
it helps you think so it helps with
creativity so I'm not even going to
refute that that's true yeah
um what's also true is addiction isn't
just this is awesome so of course I want
more of it it's actually there's there's
these little receptors in your brain
that we all have and when you take
nicotine heroin caffeine anything that's
addicted to Sugar anything and we're
dealing with a lot of them but some of
them are like 10 out of 10 on the
addictive scale yeah and nicotine's like
that so there's a nicotine receptor in
your brain
you give it nicotine it just grows
another one yeah that's what it does so
this is Ryan Adams a conflict uh noted
okay like Ryan Adams uh it takes two
when it used to take one that's
literally scientifically true meaning
The receptors start to double quadruple
triple now your brain is re this is what
Disturbed me and made me quit your brain
is rearranging itself
to a priority prioritize the acquisition
of nicotine over other behaviors wow so
it you literally become enslaved or
programmed or hypnotized or puppeted
yeah I think maybe puppeted is another
word and you're like I've actually lost
agency under the guise of this shit's
awesome yeah and that is so one once I
understood that and I was like well now
I need to starve these and that's the
good news you starve them they die yeah
these receptors die and that's what
detox is that's what withdrawal is and I
watched Nikki Glaser talking about
quitting smoking and uh she said
something like after day three it's
about the same level as of discomfort as
mild hunger which I found to be true and
so I completely got off it but I did go
through a a nicotine
I'm going to say it patch
you were you on that train oh I started
smoking when I was 10.
10 years old
or when you had reached your handsome
when I became a 10 I started so you
smoked a sneaky butt when you were 10.
yeah we got who gave it to you we got
Newports we did we got them ourselves we
what do you mean so it's me and my
friend Francis and his buddy I can't
remember his buddy's name and so we it
was like the local corner store which
was called the Cracker Barrel still
exists but it's not a Cracker Barrel
it's called the Cracker Barrel so I was
always confused when people were like
we're going to Cracker Barrel I was like
Cracker Barrel's in Chicago Hills New
Jersey and it's just a one it's just one
place you can't do that you can't be
like this is the Ground Round I know
right Pharmacy they're like we don't
give a [__] this is the Cracker Barrel
it's like naming a deli McDonald's it is
yeah yes so he so he we sent him because
he didn't live in our town and we went
to the Cracker Barrel every day so we
sent him in to buy and he bought
Newports and how old is he he was
Francis and him were 12 and I was 10.
and then we waited at Francis house and
then he called us from the pay phone and
said uh the pita bread is in the hole
and we replied with uh the fox is on its
way
oh and then we left and then we left
France's house and went into the woods
across the street from his house and we
all smoked one cigarette and then put it
into it surrounded by dry leaves that's
where you want to do it of course and
where else are you gonna smoke in New
Jersey other than the woods it was also
like Woods in a wetland so there was
like Wetlands though too and then we put
it into a plastic Ziploc bag and dug a
hole and buried it in the woods porno
style exactly porno style and then would
just come back every weekend and I think
it was like two weeks later when they
came back and they were like guess what
we were at Belmar Playland and we found
out you're supposed to inhale and we're
like I was like I was like no way no way
you're supposed to inhale it yeah and
they're like and this is how you take a
little bit of your mouth and then you go
and you bring in a lot of air too and I
was like that seems crazy and they're
like try it and I like did it and I was
like now
now I get it and I fell into like a bush
and I just remember sitting looking up
at the sky
and then a helicopter went over it I was
like there's my mom she's looking for me
she knows I'm smoking cigarettes that
was like my first thought because I was
like paranoid but you got first of all
you're reminding me I had a friend in
high school that smoked and she also for
the first year of smoking didn't know
you're supposed to inhale yeah so you're
smoking them like little cigarettes uh
like cigars I mean
yeah which you still always bothers me
that John like was almost smoking a
cigar in Romeo and Juliet one of those
little cigars and he's doing that that's
a gorilla
it doesn't look cow it doesn't look cool
no you're supposed to inhale it let it
trickle out your nose like a dragon like
that's cool like a dragon or let it come
out as you're talking like yeah but what
are you [__] coming out like you
literally look like a mythology we used
to do a thing of like just into your
mouth and then push it out and then
inhale it through your nose and if you
could do that you're very cool as a 10
year old the little whoa
yeah the whoa It's the French Exhale
yeah the French XL yeah yeah they do
that in Goodwill Hunting yeah yeah which
is where I saw all my good smoking moves
this brings us back obviously we're
still on nicotine I still don't
understand I I just had this
conversation I have to tell myself to
stop doing this and telling people what
to do I mean but a friend of mine was
like oh they're going through a divorce
and now they're smoking a lot and I was
like have you tried nicotine gum like
just get the nicotine the carbon
monoxide will get you lightheaded like
inhaling smoke kind of gives you a
different kind of high in the same way
that huffing gasoline will you know what
I mean like just trim that out
the [__] tobacco people said it
themselves remember the trials when we
were in the 90s when they made Altria
Altria yeah they stopped being Philip
Morris and they're like now we're called
Altria how dare they call themselves
something altruism I know that's real
crazy I think they're still called
Altria now whoa yeah
that's insane isn't that insane but they
say Altria I guess they just changed the
name and they're like where we what what
who yeah who are you coming after yeah
yeah we're Altria we yes we do make
Marlboro still foreign
altrua is here but uh they said in those
hearings that that cigarettes were just
a nicotine delivery system so like take
it from them yeah they have the science
what you want is nicotine so just do
nicotine but the problem is people take
nicotine gum and they chew it like a
piece of Bubblicious and it'll make you
sick yeah you gotta bite it once or
twice and then park it like and park it
like park it like dip like dip basically
yeah but I mean but as I'm saying this
to people
you realize that there are so many
unconscious desires at play one of which
is to kill yourself like I I'm not
trying to be dark people like doing
things that are destructive there's an
appeal to there's a big red button that
says do not touch or you'll die and we
like to lick the button we like to rub
our ass on it like and it looks cool
yeah we I mean I I'm not the first one
to make this point but like
I'm so practical and a science
experiment that I'm like just go to the
finish line and get the chemical that
you like but really people wanna it's
fun to be sad and smoking too that what
I actually miss most about smoking is
um being somewhere and going outside
with one other person
and having five to eight minutes of
alone time outside you're stealing a a
bit well I think we did this on the beat
home show it's like I don't like smoking
I like leaving bars yeah yeah
and I love it I said if there was a cup
of tea that if you ordered it you had to
drink it outside that's so great I would
be like I would love that too that would
be constantly it's just like highly
sensitive introverted people yeah which
by the way are more uh prone to smoke I
believe interesting somebody told me
that the fundamental core negative
belief of a smoker is I am I'm alone oh
and it is and and how they it bonds you
with other ones is like the remedy oh
that's interesting yeah right because
it's not everybody who goes out for the
smoke it's just the two it's just the
two yeah and also it'll get you lots of
sex which I always not lots of sex I'm
just saying that's how people are
meeting each other yeah exactly leave
the bar it's so funny too of like uh of
that cigarette that you share with a
person and then then you go to kiss them
and then it's just like cigarette mouth
two cigarettes two ashes it's like both
of you have the garlic with clams yeah
exactly so it doesn't matter but also I
was just I have a bit about this too
where it's like in junior high school I
drank my soda and then a girl asked me
for a second soda she drinks the soda by
the transitive property we've now kissed
and it's the same thing well they say
like things don't change grown-ups just
have different things I take a drag you
take a drag or or if a woman takes the
cigarette from you and does it yeah
she's saying like we're still like Jane
Goodall should still be studying us just
around the corner just going like ah to
demonstrate that I don't think cooties I
don't think your germs are a threat to
me yeah I mean I think genetically we
are simpatico meaning like what your
immune system can fight off mine can
fight off meaning what does that mean we
could have children
when I take your cigarette and take a
puff from it it's saying I could have
your children
[Music]
no I know yeah I get it I guess there's
those cues of course do you love the way
that Lauren smells
um yes I do did it change after she had
the baby oh I don't know probably not
then okay because that's a phenomenon I
was are you aware of it nervous of yeah
oh it didn't happen oh okay I'm obsessed
with how Val smells so I and this is
sort of this is a little weird because
now by the transit property I'm saying
I'm obsessed with how I smell but valve
smells very similar to me she smells so
interesting familiar to me that's then
you notice that immediately I noticed it
after we started sleeping together but I
was sort of like oh wow this this person
doesn't because what what am I really
saying they don't smell to me right like
smell means unfamiliar like if you're
like what's that smell I mean like I'm
not used to this even though you and I
were essentially you're kind of like
saturated in smells that are normal to
you so Val doesn't smell but there is a
phenomenon this is good fodder for your
podcast not really it's not like a news
we did we did there is a news story that
I was going to tell you about it for
bananas weird I picked up friends
friends choose friends circles based on
smell
not surprised yeah not surprised we did
it a little while ago right yeah friends
choose the friends that's appear in
their Circle based on pheromones yeah I
think there's a lot of information going
on if someone tastes repulsive to you
very hard to get over I that was I had a
girlfriend okay if I did it for two
years the very first time we ever hooked
up I was like I don't like the way that
she tastes and but then we still dated
and it was the most damaging
relationship I've ever been in I wonder
how they felt about you I wonder if if
she was bad to you I bet you were bad to
her yes right yeah yeah I I've said it a
million poor Katie for everybody for me
I mean think of how many times I've
heard it but dating if you date based on
smell yeah like if you find your partner
based on smell and there's different
ways of doing that uh one just take a
big old whiff uh very good success rate
yeah and this is I think this is
disturbing to us oh well we want to have
agency we want a free will we do really
want to have it really it's like sorry
sucker you're like amoebas and you're
microbiome and you're [__] are your
tofu your hormones it really is smells
like familiar and yeah I mean like I
agree 100 that whole idea of like
whether or not we have agency is
actually I think a big question but
the night that I met my wife I knew that
we were going to get married and I said
it to I was with Eugene Merman and my
friend Chris oslin on a Super Deluxe set
on a supreme going on I don't think this
is going to last but you know what will
last me and that girl who's on a date
right now with somebody else for real
for real yeah she was on a date with
somebody else at the time Todd Berry no
she claims it wasn't a day she claims it
wasn't a date
you shut the [__] up
so uh you like breadsticks and then in
comes I claim it was a date she says it
wasn't a date they were just buddies
going to a show together uh and I was
like zero chance
the rules
ruling has been handed down I'm not
saying Todd skeezy or anything I'm not
saying Lauren is a beautiful woman yeah
Todd is is a single uh guy and uh
there's no way he was like right I'm
going on a friend day but she was
literally like getting in a car leaving
with Todd and I'd like seen her at the
bar for like five minutes and had like a
very short conversation with her earlier
uh and then I was like there it is there
she goes pretty drunk There She Goes
marry her and like Chris was like okay
all right buddy all right get in the car
okay and Eugene is going stupendous
he's just saying some Eugene word I
thought that was right and I thought
Katie was laughing and I looked at her
and she wasn't which is okay no I
thought saw you go like a big left but I
think it was over by the time I got to
you this is not even worth mentioning
but it's funny to just look at a neutral
face and be like stupendous you do not
have to perform for us Katie please be
comfortable
um she is after 7 000 episodes yeah
she's doing just fine has it been 10
years more than over 10 years yeah wow
we're in the 700s
11 million years
[Music]
so here's what I love about your story
you talk to her yeah which means you
smelled her yeah it happened yeah it
happened I tried for the longest time to
get a joke about how our genitals smell
like our armpits and so when two
athletes like boxers are hugging each
other they're like smelling each other
they can smell each other's dicks yeah
yeah yeah and they're awful they're
getting so close I've seen like I'm sure
they smell each other's actual dicks as
well but they're very close if you talk
about wrestlers on the way down
are you talking about like Fighters I'm
talking about wrestlers wrestlers
wrestlers they're getting detained yeah
they know the difference between the
three regions as they call it the balls
the taint and the [__] they're like
like it was dark but where would the
coaches like where were you in the
regions I do wonder if wrestlers who are
like very serious about it just like
don't shower for a couple days before
matches so that they're they make
whatever is happening to the other
person like the most uncomfortable and
also to just dominate to smell Dominic
yeah if you're showering and shampooing
before a wrestling match I don't know
anything other than the movie Fox
catcher about wrestling you're doing it
absolutely wrong in fact what is a
wrestling match except two smells
battling for dominance which of these
smells will be on top
I remember when we did when Kristen and
I did uh the Melbourne Comedy Festival
in 2008 uh I wore a suit for every
single show and it was 28 shows in 30
days I did not wash the suit and we did
Chris and Charles a horse at the end
where I was just of course pouring sweat
and it was summertime pouring sweats yes
uh that was the worst smell I've ever
I've heard uh Sasha bear Cove yeah for
Borat you uh so you heard the same thing
that Sasha bear code didn't wash his
washes his suit because he wouldn't
right Borat wouldn't immediately puts
people also in a on the back foot I
think well isn't Borat and the way
people treat Borat an extension I'm
feeling very lofty today but I think
it's an extension of how we deal with
things like smell uncontrollable
cultural differences are sort of like
uncontrollable smells like bodies yeah
yeah and they're foreign smells and
there's yes and they're foreign and you
don't know how her smells handled in
your community right it's like a big
thing do you okay so I did this pilot uh
on uh Katie has heard me talk about this
uh it was poor Katie
this was a high end we learned it was
all okay it was all for Katie Katie
Katie's chess pieces tell the story
again
it was a pilot I believe for AMC back in
2000 like two or something and it was a
based on a British prank show that they
were trying to bring to America and
there was a character that existed
already in the UK and was successful I
played this character it's called Mr
stinks they took a suit and they doused
it in skunk and coyote urine and it and
just like the most disgusting smells
like as I put the suit on I would start
gagging if the sketch doesn't end with
one round bald man with glasses that
goes hello
that's how we need it we need it no what
it was Mr stinks Mr stinks and it was so
upsetting it was so upsetting and I feel
horrible for having participated in it
uh then women would set their friends up
on blind dates with me is this the same
one with the ventriloquist same show
different show drop the mic you are the
caster you know but you are central
casting's idea of this guy looks your
equal parts won't prank me and you will
prank yeah yeah you're like a perfect
Arnold Palmer yeah of like I'm
disgusting it's like ambition I could
see him doing something horrible but I
could also see someone not seeing
something horrible from him coming yeah
that's you he's either a math teacher or
a pedophile that's exactly right yes
that's exactly right so I would have to
go on blind dates with these women they
would come and I would like immediately
get up and hug them and then they would
sit down and it was just the prank was
just waiting to see how long it took for
them to leave
I'm full of death that you hugged them
yeah and did anyone did it just end
there nope everyone went with it
everyone went with it and that is the
one woman out of five I think one woman
within like a minute was just like you
know I have to go to the bathroom and
then she just never came back and then
the others were just like so very nice
and they didn't know they're on TV
they're just being nice they they won
the that wasn't there a prank show
called Tipping Point or something there
was there was a practice boiling point
boiling point yeah where they would try
to aggravate you you made it to a
certain point do that now no because
people pull out a gun and shoot somebody
that's absolutely right yeah there's
your boiling point right here you get
people to pull a gun
this is this is the New Prague show can
we get someone to pull a gun on us
that's crazy that's fantastic boy you
just made me think well there was that
Darren who's the magician guy Darren oh
um
Carter the party starter that's a
comedian Karen poor guy he probably is
so sick of being called during Carter
the party starter Aaron Carter you mean
is it Aaron Carter is Aaron is Aaron
Carter The Carter party starter he's
dead he just died Aaron Carter yeah oh
the pop musician yeah no no no no no no
okay are you talking about yeah and then
there's another magician who tried to
make a person take a bullet for him and
he does it it's a Netflix special it's
crazy wow with conditioning will you
look up magician atheist skeptic and I
think it's Darren okay
he's like his whole thing is disproving
most things and and kind of what we've
been talking about is like we are
reactive systems and like oh can I get
this guy who's a race Darren Brown
Darren Brown very fascinating okay doing
work that like he like I'm gonna be
upset on his behalf if he was doing what
he's doing now and for the past 15 years
in the 90s he'd be Oprah Winfrey like
because it's only a testament to there
being too much content that I'm telling
you that there's a special a magic
special where he takes a racist guy
has him go through a series of
deprogramming exercises one of which I
remember is gazing with an illegal
immigrant of Mexican descent so they
stare at each other's eyes and he's
crying like completely cracking him open
and then using like suggestive sounds
like sound triggers that like trigger
certain thoughts it's too it takes an
hour to explain in the show and it works
at the end they set up a situation where
someone's going to shoot an illegal
immigrant and the guy dives in front of
the bullet what yeah it's also you know
what else is the other problem about
about the special I'm realizing in the
retelling there's a thing in Magic where
things can't be too amazing because
there's a threshold a threshold of
belief a threshold actually of I think
belief is a yeah I might use the word
acceptance okay or like imagine if I
just held my hand up like this and then
like
something appeared there that's actually
too amazing right for you to even
because I would be like there has to be
I don't even know what you do it's like
the Matrix like you wouldn't accept it
and I wouldn't accept you like if you
disappeared and the mic fell to the
ground not fun but if I put that script
screaming exactly that that's part of it
I throw all the cameras out there but
think about it what the best magic trick
in the world is the way the human animal
works is we'd like there to be a
Crossroads a a hinge we're in something
funky might happen but we don't know
what it is but we don't just want to see
magic yeah if we did would go see the
aurora borealis somewhere right I'm just
saying uh you'd like me to cover myself
with a blanket but and then I'm gone
that right that yes but if I just
disappeared it would be like too much
it's it's like an assault it's an
assault it would be terrifying yeah I
remember day David Blaine showed up on
the street once when we were outside
always on the street that guy always on
the street he did this thing and I
watched him do it fascinating took a
coin took a quarter out of I think it
was my pocket or somebody else's pocket
and had our friend Ashley write her name
on it with a sharpie uh then he put it
in her hand put his hands over her hand
and then when she opened it up it was
bent in half with her signature on it
wow I mean it was just like what and you
and then he gave it to her like so she
had a bent Corridor a lot of overhead
and being a magician gotta give away
those props you gotta give them away
and look I'll talk about magic with you
all day the worst thing that I can say
is that you or not the worst thing but
you don't actually want to know having
known a lot of musicians and done a lot
of study in Magic you don't you it's
always very upsetting It's upsetting
it's like finding out that comedians are
really just like highly sensitive
neurotic narcissists you know what I
mean it's like wow that guy was a man he
delighted us for an hour and it's like
yeah his life is
but like David Blaine one of the coolest
[__] in the world when you find
out he has a pocket full of half-folded
quarters yeah that's a dork yeah yeah he
jingle Jangles with half folded quarters
a lot of David's uh David like I know
him a lot of his tricks a lot of Mr
blanes are very basic tricks done
incredibly well like the cigarette
through the through the coin is like
classic back of the back of the catalog
comic book trick he just does it
incredibly well uh so I'm not let's not
even talk about how he maybe did it
because that's incredible yeah I will
ask did he get her to sign more than one
quarter no that doesn't even apply it
doesn't even apply it was just one
quarter it has to be
it makes me think it's a some sort of
mechanism like it is the quarter like
somehow yeah I have a quarter it doesn't
matter this is boring no no that's what
it is it's what it is it's like that he
switches the quarter out in his hands
and we can't see he puts a folded one
but how it gets signed and this is
really where you get into the into the
muck of it is when you consider a staff
when you consider magicians at that
level are it's not just one person right
you're looking at the grassy knoll
you're looking at like three Shooters
yeah meaning like sometimes I'll have
you sign I know I'll have you I'm just
totally disrespectful in November no
less the month had happened uh I only
know that because it's my brother's
birthday I get you to sign a card and
then 20 minutes later I help you you
have to sign the same card now I have
two Ace of Spades with your signature on
it which is why magic I don't know why
I'm talking about this I'm gonna stop
but like magic hinges on the principle
that there's a social tension that you
won't do the thing like for example you
won't sign your name in a ridiculous
Banner you won't like black out the card
right like your name if you do if you do
then they just move on and if you do a
different trick yeah that's right
absolutely yeah it's fascinating I don't
know why more comedians aren't
fascinated with magic because yeah it
really is I remember one stewart shows I
was in London and it was John benjarin
and Nathan Fielder and we're all doing
shows together with Eugene at the Soho
theater and Nathan Fielder and John
Benjamin argued about magic for four
hours outside to the point where it
ruined the night for everyone yeah and
job Benjamin was just like magic stupid
Nathan feeling was like magic is awesome
and it just went through like Nathan
Builder even more four I already left so
long it went on for so long I watched um
one of my buddy Elliot Terrell I hope
I'm saying that right Elliot he listens
to this podcast he's a great magician
and a great tailor anyway he was doing
magic behind Largo he did my show or he
was at my show or something and he did
Magic for Sarah Silverman who was the
worst Magic audience I've ever seen in
my life
as someone who knows the tension of
doing a trick yeah imagine Sarah
Silverman yeah who I don't care Elliot
looked very cool the whole time he
handled it like a pro in fact most of
magic is just keeping your heart rate
down yeah that seems to be most of it
and she's just going like take a car oh
you want me to take this one well I'm
gonna take that like just every single
way like put it over here oh so you can
swap it I was just like
like just be tricked yeah let it happen
he tricked yeah life sucks like I'm not
saying it sucks but like we're so rarely
dazzled bedazzled and when it when you
don't know it's a mystery yes and the
answer and that's true about all of
life's mysteries yes the answer sucks
yeah the enjoy the mystery that's right
that is the one thing I do kind of like
about
Catholicism I was raised in Catholic and
I'm not Catholic anymore but that like
the idea that yeah well there's a
there's the father Son and the Holy
Ghost and they're the same thing but
also different and it's a mystery yeah
and that's how it is just like shut up
don't ask questions about it yeah uh but
I do I don't like it in that context but
I do like the it in like the magic
context because everything when you get
the answer it's never said but even in
in I would call it healthy religion the
ones that say we don't know yeah we have
a series of symbols that can bring you
towards or closer to even this language
is wrong closer to the experience of
let's just call it reality you don't
have to call it like the truth of
whether or not there's this or this or
this but just like actual reality like
dropping your own Hang-Ups long enough
to be cleanly in the moment and like
actually a plugged in member of the
whole yeah meaning the whole solar
system the whole Multiverse all that
sort of stuff uh they're like these this
is a bunch of lie this is a truth so big
it can only be told with lies that's one
of my favorite uh talk about metaphor
right not just religion oh that's
interesting they're like some truths are
so big it's Richard Rory he says it's a
truth so big it can only be told with
lies and he goes
um always true sometimes really happen
and I'm like when I heard he's Catholic
he's Franciscan yeah when I heard
someone say that in like I'm not
Catholic but still in the vestment yeah
I was like
this guy's gonna get it's like a rapper
that's calling out the wrong rappers
he's like you can't talk smack about
them they'll come at you but he's been
doing that for for 30 30 years you know
what I just flashed on when you were
talking about that is when we took
mushrooms and went up into the mountains
in Colorado yes and we went up to that
Alpine Lake and we're all sitting on
this giant rock and then this duck just
one duck made a bee line for us yeah
that was a ridge block was said he was
like oh here comes this dark duck
he knows he knows and he's like hey guys
you haven't you guys got any uh oh what
did it called you guys got any Jazz
cigarettes laughs
the narc duck it was just one duck and
of course he was like later when I
thought about it I was like he's used to
being fed and so he thought maybe we had
food but in that moment I was like this
duck is coming for us that's like ramnas
who's right there when he took uh
psilocybin for the first time they all
became convinced that the dog was dying
because it was just like laying there
yeah yeah
they were like it's breathing weird but
the truth is this is what what uh I
don't even want to say drugs but things
like psilocybin are great for is it
shows you what you've never paid
attention to yeah have you ever just
watched a dog breathing the answer is no
yeah so when you are in that captivated
place and you watch it you're like is
this normal it's actually kind of
there's something kind of French and
hauntingly beautiful about like you
don't know because you never looked yeah
you know what I mean something French
there's something French about that yeah
here's something boy I don't think
Kristen would mind I remember
on that hike because it was kind of a
hike yeah since then I've decided I
don't like hiking on no that's the only
time I've ever done it yeah that was the
only time I've ever done it and since
then I'm like and we were also so high
up I'm shocked that we were like all
okay the the altitude yeah yeah there
was a lot going on there yeah there was
a lot going on but Kristen this is the
thing it's not that mean I was on
mushrooms yeah but she was wearing like
a fisherman's cap and dark like Oakleys
yeah like big ones yeah like big like
too big for her face yeah and once the
drugs kicked in I I found it hard to
look at her like it was very confusing
let's put it this way no part of me went
that's Kristen Shaw after the drugs
kicked and I was like she looked like
the sketch on like a a like something
you'd staple to a telephone uh poll have
you seen this man
like a Unabomber sketch yeah and I was
like we're on a mushroom fueled hike
there's Kurt there's Val there's Rich
pouring sweat like we're going down
why that trip was
it's not often that I I haven't taken
much I talk about motions a lot but I
haven't taken them that many times but
that trip I remember
specifically thinking because I didn't
take enough which is one of the most
frustrating experiences of Life whatever
it may be
but I was like
[__] I was too scared I took too little
and now when I one of my mushroomy kind
of feelings is I start seeing things
painted in a very fine gold like a gold
yellow but with the finest brush
imaginable and you'll that's where
you'll see like eyes are like an
Egyptian sort of God or something yeah
like just kind of like it's like here's
reality and they're right behind that
Veil and you can kind of just see them
dancing a little bit that's one of my
classic I'm on mushroom feelings and I
could kind of see them and then they'd
fade away they're like sorry not enough
yeah and I but then I remember thinking
isn't it weird and I still think it is
that fundamental reality like the
deepest craziest mystery of the I'm
gonna say the unknowable source of
existence is always true meaning it's
not my ability to tune into it like okay
I saw Sunset and the birth of my child
or whatever like that's all great but
okay also when I'm making a peanut
butter and jelly sandwich and I'm
depressed or like I haven't had my
coffee or I'm tired
that reality let's call it the fine
painted gold Sphinx orgy is in the sense
I know it's a hallucination we could
disregard it but to me it's a it's a
symbol of a deeper reality is always
there does that resonate with you uh yes
and also it's a it's a way of also
recognizing that like even in the uh
even in the most banal moments there is
a there is a like a beauty and a mystery
to the moment itself yes if you can open
yourself up to it and what I think try
to remember all the time is like it's
there even if I can't perceive it and
that is incredibly good news meaning it
is good news whatever this is
and this is I'm just doing an undulating
kind of squid resistance existence Alan
Watts calls it like when you hit a Gong
it's like
but it's like yes and which like
connects right up with uh particle
physics does it yeah everything being a
wave and you're a surfer yeah the only
waves we can interact with exactly but
there's something that we're drawn to
waves the rise and the fall and all of
that sort of stuff but that particle
physics thing
even if you're having the most closed
off pinched dark I'm alone this sucks
this is meaningless you're still like it
or not
a key ingredient in
in that in that moment and when you
consider the time
is is just how we perceive reality
really
that's that's irrelevant too yeah
I was I just I started reading this book
that I think you would like it's called
Uh the physicist guide to existentialism
uh and it's like physics explaining like
uh a philosophical ideas oh well and the
very first one that they do is
um like are my is my grandmother who's
dead is my grandmother actually alive
still uh and and then she breaks it down
hoffenbender I think is her name uh she
breaks it down of like how like by
Einstein's theory of general relativity
and special relativity that yes like all
time exists right now simultaneously yes
um and that there is it just depends on
where you are in space-time precisely
yeah [__] hey love that yeah you
should check that out it's really
interesting this is this guide to
existentialism yeah I love that
uh again I already mentioned Rupert
Spire but again a lot of I find that if
you don't like it meaning I'm going to
use spiritual language or psychological
language if your ego doesn't like it I
actually think that's a pretty good sign
that you're you're probably reading
something that may be true yes meaning
it's not satisfying to the story of Pete
or the story of Kurt and what Rupert
Spira has articulated so beautifully
he's like your life is like a book and
it's all been written but the way we
perceive it is word by word line by line
Page by Page and that's time
that's pretty interesting yeah isn't
that great yeah so we say this all the
time eternity or Infinity
eternity is better because we're talking
about time
eternity doesn't mean never-ending time
it means the book it means the book no
yeah oh I'm sorry I thought you were
doing a riff no no but it means the book
and also but we're locked into reading
at a specific rate and we can't go
backwards or forwards that's interesting
in fact that's a that's an illusion but
it's all happening
eternity means no time so all of this
actually is happening in a Timeless
instant yeah but the way that we I would
say graciously perceive it it's almost
like when people smoke DMT or something
it's like
and it's like yeah because you've
removed the again I would say kind kind
mechanism yeah that goes no let's let's
go the best way to go through space-time
in this way this is the best way to do
it it's the least this thing is this
thing is like the Vonnegut thing for
like how we experience time right he
talks about it in I don't know maybe
Sirens a Titan but that the Tralf
midorians these alien race they see time
as like one like mountain landscape and
we are on a railroad track looking
through a pipe at just one part of the
mountain and we're moving it like just
this pace but they see the whole
Mountain okay so I hope he doesn't mind
me tell I won't say who it is just in
case they wouldn't a friend of mine and
I've never done that in DMT but like he
smoked DMT I have not uh yeah it's a
little it sounds scary it does sound
scary yeah if I'm being if you want to
reduce it all to it I go
it's just jumping into a Whirlpool of
infinity and it's Buck Rogers and I'm
afraid I'm afraid
and I'm terrified all of them well I
mean it's I caught Buck Rogers it's a
little Two Buck Rogers for me yeah I
always use this example but my friend
smoked and he was inside of a giant crab
in a Coliseum fighting another crab to
the death and I was like because for me
uh those these substances are Are
Spiritual increase meaning existential
or metaphysical inquiries I'm like I
don't know what is gained by that yeah
by that Revelation yeah like I won
I was the crab that won I had somebody
say like if you have that experience
it's hard to take this one seriously and
I'm like okay I can see that I'm still
just not called to it yeah but my friend
did it
and he had a very interesting experience
similar to your Vonnegut thing which he
was in a another place and he was like
time was in that place was like a a
bundle of wire like picture your box of
Christmas lights okay you open it and
it's just all yeah tangled up and he's
like this was a universe where every
being in that Universe could revisit any
moment in their life at any time yeah
and revisit it and if you wanted to just
stay at the moment where you had a
three-way you could just go and yeah
just do that forever and he was again a
lot of them did and he was like but a
lot of them he was very surprised went
to the bad moments which is honestly the
way our minds work I'm not surprised
like we get so much identity and so much
meaning and so much of that good I exist
feeling from our Trauma from our
disagreements from from our altercations
all that sort of stuff but he was like
uh you could go to the moment you died
you could go to when you were born and
he just and I was like how long were you
there and he was like that question
makes absolutely no sense to me like I
was there yeah and if you were there
you're there you were there and he was
like I have as many memories from that
experience as I do my own life would you
prefer to know when or how you die
I'd rather know
how
you're waiting for me to reconsider no I
don't I don't know if I don't know I
don't think when right if we talk
through it like when seems
terrifying because if you know that it's
even if you know it's in 25 years yeah
then every day I'd just be going like 20
40 years exactly you know right if you
know the date then you're like well I've
got 15 years left I probably shouldn't
start on this new thing yeah I'm not
gonna be able to finish it learn
Portuguese right yeah that's why I'm
going with how I thought that on the way
in and I'm having a nice time with you
and I don't think it's unrelated to the
fact that as I was driving it I
remembered you could die today yeah and
that actually I love the word imbues but
it imbues my day with added richness in
fact I've considered starting with but
I'll never do it because it's too weird
but like having me in the and the guest
read a statement and in that statement
would be like we acknowledge that we
will one day be dead yeah and people
will or won't listen to this but this
will exist and we'll be dead but like
that
bad shows bad podcasts both hinge on for
me and it's just a guess these people
are thinking about what they're going to
do after this meaning they'll withhold a
laugh because they're wondering how or
they're distracted or they're distracted
yeah exactly and sometimes they'll say
audiences I go let's just pretend this
is the last thing we're ever going to do
yeah and that would be great comedy like
if you could really go like at the end
of this week explode can you imagine
that show yeah and some comedians are I
don't know if anyone's doing it but
getting closer than others and I don't
mean being like [__] you [__] everybody
you know like or some grotesque
confession I mean like actually doing
and I'm trying to do it with you I think
you're doing a pretty nice job I think
we're doing it today is a good day to
die today is a good day to die that
movie freaked me out what there's a
movie oh yeah it opens with um
flat flatliners oh Kiefer Sutherland it
opens with this huge oh it's Flatline
crane shot and he goes today's a good
day today really oh I had the first line
of the movie
and the premise of that ladder is very
DMT yes they die oh you remember oh yeah
no I saw it in the theaters I think okay
I just don't remember the opening line
yeah I remember
I could I didn't see the whole movie was
actually worse
like it would have been better to like
see the conclusion but I just yeah I
stopped watching it became heart rate
which becomes and then I was like
there's no exploration stopped I still
have that like I remember briefly I was
very interested in astral projection you
know what that is I think so yeah it's
leaving your body yeah you're watching
yourself you know who says he did it
Sinbad for real yeah Sinbad did this
podcast and said that he could astral
projected and he said he stopped doing
it because something attacked him and he
was like I'm not doing that anymore whoa
so the times that I this is again talk
about pre-kids yeah but before I had
kids I was sitting on my bed with a
copper pyramid trying to astral protect
her whatever it was and I would get
what's weird and even if you remove the
the woo-woo from it yeah what's weird is
you can lay down and imagine like a
portal above your head pulling yourself
out and you'll start to convulse like
that's just facts which is just you
could call it the placebo effect the
power of suggestion yeah whatever it is
it's crazy that you can like start going
nuts it's like Aaron's right there and
who Darren oh my Darren's right there
he's doing it this is a bit tough didn't
it is he British yeah oh I didn't know
that they all are all all the all the
all the most uh
vocal atheists that are like yeah it's a
bunch of nonsense isn't it they're all
British which is so funny because their
whole culture is like God saved it's
probably part of it anyway I'm talking
too much have you ever seen a UFO
no ghost
no ever almost die
close I mean like not like well I know I
didn't know
I was surfing in Rockaway probably this
is when I still had my I.T job I worked
I.T and uh and I've been out and it was
getting bigger and I've been on a long
board it was getting bigger and so I I
had I had a bungalow that was like a you
know right two houses in from the beach
and uh so I wanted to switch out to a
short board and so I brought the board
back and then I got a phone call from
work because I had just left work in the
middle of the day to go surfing and they
were like calling me like what the [__]
like there's a problem and so I had to
be on the phone and I think I was on the
phone longer than I thought I had been
on the phone and so when I came back the
waves have gotten way bigger but I did I
just assumed I was gone for like five
minutes they must be similar to what it
was before yeah and uh and I paddled out
on there was a way to get out at Rock
and uh at you paddle out on the left
hand side of the jetty at 91st Street
and it's kind of like a little conveyor
belt so the water comes in and then
pulls out along the jetty so you just
kind of get into it and it kind of sucks
you out around the rocks and then you're
on the other side where the brake is
and so that means there's a moment where
you are in front of the jetty which is
just all big giant rocks and the waves
are coming towards you but usually you
just get sucked out and it's really fast
but I had not noticed how much bigger it
had gotten and as I was getting kind of
like sucked out around in front it just
so happened that there was a set a huge
set coming in that I couldn't get past
and it was I was right in front of the
rocks and so I just remember having no
time but I I just tried to punch through
it I just tried to duck dive as much as
I could
but the wave was already it was already
cresting over my head so I'm pushing
through the face of the wave and then
the like they just got picked up and
went backwards and then landed on the
Rocks but I mean what happened was
the water had just because I'd punched
through maybe like I don't know eight
inches or something into the face of the
wave that water was behind me so it hit
the Rocks first and almost made like a
cushion and then I I flowed off the
Rocks never actually hitting any rocks
even though I know they were right there
just enough and if I had not gotten that
like six or eight inches in I would have
landed on a rock point on my spine well
that's what he said
that's what he said if you hadn't gotten
that six eight inches in
um sorry I'm watching a lot of the
office uh that is horrible yeah and I'm
so glad you're okay and
is there anything like the ocean that
can go from fun to sheer Terrors isn't
it amazing that's what's so amazing
about it when you go that's what I
always would love going to the same
Beach like multiple times like
throughout the course of the year and
see how radically different it looks
yeah on like a calm day and what it's
like to be there and then on during a
hurricane and what it's like to be there
during a snowstorm what it's like to be
there yes totally different places
noticing the dog breathing by the way
yeah that's what I think is sort of
when I say holy I mean it's whole like
you're having the full experience when
you're when you're surfing even you
talking about knowing the the you know
current around a jetty is very much more
in line with how human beings have been
for the majority of our existence is
like knowing which way the wind blows
knowing where animals would be exactly
knowing which berries you would eat and
we're so disconnected from that knowing
which ones are boys and bearing which
one are poison berries
joke if there's ever a bit that I wrote
that you could have absolutely I love
that joke I remember doing it at your
show in New York I remember seeing it
for the first I remember the first time
I saw it it was that invite them up and
I was like that's a [__] amazing oh
my God and that's so great and like a
lot of those jokes it died a bloody
death so many times really on on the
road places where they're down the road
yeah there's a lot of bits like that
that I love but they do hinge a lot on
either pinch header phenomenon meaning
it's funny if you're the third comedian
in a lineup and you're doing a joke like
that and it's very novel yes now you're
not talking about relationships you're
not talking about your job this guy just
brought up boys and boys how weird yeah
but if you're just like the ACT if
you're just the evening's entertainment
you're not juxtaposed against anything
except maybe your opener yeah and people
are like oh this is what we're here to
exp this is what we're gonna exactly the
the benign violation of the joke meaning
isn't it stupid that I'm talking about
this actually becomes a disappointment
to the audience that it would rather you
relate to their lives yes isn't that
fascinating I've never heard it stated
that way because I have that problem I
know I I don't mean I know I know
because you and I are similar yeah the
other problem that that you and I I'm
assuming could have I'll say I have is
that if I'm doing 15 minutes I have
jokes that are like forget it but if you
do that same joke after already watching
me for 30 minutes you might only be okay
now yeah whereas I'm like I know if you
took that joke and just opened with it
yeah it would be unbelievable but
there's like a because again part of the
joke is the material selection yeah and
after they know the type of material you
select it's going to be less funny yeah
because the surprise is gone unless
you're continually surprise them exactly
yeah but if you like me
I sometimes go dirty I sometimes go
absurd I sometimes go silly it's you
can't rely on the like I can't believe
he's talking about this 30 minutes into
your act that's why the second leg of a
special is always
so much harder yeah and why every time I
tape a special I'm like why don't I just
tape for 15 minutes sets that's more
indicative because that's not what it is
I have and I can't wait for you to watch
the news special because I do have
something that happens around the 35
minute Mark that changes oh well the
tone of the whole thing and that was
something I remember and I don't know if
you've ever noticed this but I remember
asking David
um David o'dougherty who is uh uh about
you know his advice for an hour-long
Festival show and he said something
surprising must happen at 40 minutes
because at 40 minutes is when the human
body physically wants to no longer be
seated and that's when you start losing
people but if you surprise them with
something that's completely new uh at 40
minutes they'll they'll stay for the
next 15. to get to 55 minutes and I
noticed one thing that he just did which
was very simple during one of his
Festival shows he just said okay well
you know let me finish up and all of a
sudden you're like he's ending and but
he did it at the 40 minute Mark and he
didn't end for another 15 minutes but
because he said let me finish up it just
changed it yeah where it's like oh we're
not in the middle of the show anymore
we're at the end brilliant but then it
was 15 more minutes till it ended that's
an old uh like public speaking there
again I got this from ramdas but it's a
trick to say in conclusion yeah like
it's a trick yeah to get again the human
animal to go like wait what what what's
ending already interesting yeah my
theory and I don't really stick to this
is you should have a closer every 15
minutes which is really interesting
because I know I'm talking about your
old special but you actually you open
really I'm obsessed with how special is
open I know I'm talking about your old
expression but like
you open with this incredibly strong
canoe bit which I'm like you could close
with that yeah I think that's so helpful
and then about 10 minutes in you do a
bit the masturbation bit uh Lauren
walking in on you like that's a closer
if I've ever heard one and that's what I
try to do I when I look at my set list
I'm like I just want a really big one
every four four bits big one four bits
big ones interesting yeah so when you
close you're actually closing for the
fifth the fourth third and then I like
to do double closer if I can I know that
sounds incredibly yeah strange but like
I like to because again that old special
of yours you go this is my big finale I
I feel feel a similar burden meaning
like yeah my clothes are sort of out of
nowhere and sometimes closers are so why
not just do two if you have them yeah
yeah yeah if you have them if you
haven't well I can't wait I'm very
excited for you to watch the new I'm
very excited to see it maybe and maybe
I'll do uh I'll do it on on that
platform yeah I mean what I'm curious
yeah so maybe we'll have a after it's
all said and done I sound I sound like a
nerd I'm all stuffed up
do you feel any I was going to ask you
this before but when you're on your
board in the ocean and I know I actually
remember pretty vividly our religious
discussion last time because I believe
your mom had just passed and it's funny
I I mean it as a compliment if I
remember something from an episode we
did over 10 years ago a long time ago
like so it really had an impact on me
but uh giving you allowance to Alan
Watts says you're under no obligation to
be the person you were 30 seconds ago
but like when you're
surfing so many poets forget Mystics
forget religious thinkers but like just
poets or like talk about the ocean yeah
and feel
I I look at the ocean I get emotional I
look at it I'm like again
the way we perceive time feels kind and
gentle and the fact that we're on a
thing with a thing the ocean that really
seems to answer every question even the
questions we can't articulate but I see
the Regeneration of the ocean I see the
flow of the ocean I see the apparent
division of the ocean meaning here's a
wave but we know that the ocean is
really all just one thing it just really
seems to answer a lot and maybe even you
can't articulate it but when you're on
your board
looking at waves from the back which I
think is such a unique perspective
do you feel connected do you get a sense
or or let me just ask this without
leading you more than I already have
what are those feelings what are those
thoughts and they is that part of what
you like about it yes 100 what I like
about it it is a uh
uh it is an emptiness that feels full I
I would say that that is how I feel when
I Surf and that is yeah I'll remember
that in 10 years an emptiness that feels
full is wonderful and and I sometimes
I'll have to I'll have to help myself
get there because I'll have a song stuck
in my head and that is for me at least
I've noticed when I'm looking for that
emptiness that feels full you know
moment my ego wants to hold on to
control and the song is often the way
the ego attempts to hold on to control
it would rather you hear the song Rock
Lobster than vanish yeah yeah it would
rather Rock Lobster be on repeat without
knowing all of the words exactly that's
right
that's right and then just repeating one
little piece of it absolutely and would
rather waste your [__] time
absolutely and so I have to quiet that
that's the only active work I'm doing is
actively trying to quiet the the ego
playing songs in my head I find that so
helpful again not I'm going to use
spiritual language but like there's no
devil but there is an Impulse to Rob
yourself
you lose what you rob from yourself yeah
if that makes sense and you and what is
revealed is what you reveal to yourself
there's this weird
dual thing meaning both of those
archetypal energies are in you yeah I
totally know what you mean the days that
I have where I just can't quite
watch the dog breathe yeah even if I'm
in the ocean and I'm serving it doesn't
mean I'm necessarily going to have a
great time right because I'm still
no matter where you go there you are and
if there's a part of you that's
unregulated regulated I don't want to
make it sound like too much of a
discipline but it does take an awareness
to go more of an awareness because the
discipline seems scary to me absolutely
where you're like I'm gonna beat this
out of me I think it's way more gentle
than that it's way more just like and
forgiving noticing and I would even say
forgiving yeah being like that's okay
that's okay I see what's happening I
know what this is almost saying I know
what it is it releases it I think that's
exactly right yeah deeply profound also
being earthed is really important and
the ocean is grounding and people say I
don't know negative ions and all that
[__] but that's right yeah where you
have great Thoughts by breaking water
have you heard that yeah like Moodle and
from what I can tell it's true yeah
usually we should find out from like the
people who run the ferries at Niagara
Falls
yeah are they the happiest people do
they kill themselves less often than
like dentists or whatever yeah that
would be disappointing
I noticed that like even in a hot tub or
something like again that's grounding
yeah but also the water is moving and
there's just something about that I know
it sounds woo but it really I it seems
to me that there's some research to it
or whatever I think there is but I don't
know it yeah have your have do you have
any just just to we don't and then I'll
ask you the last question I'm David
orders getting here it is
um
any new feelings about the the nature of
what's Happening
um like something's happening yeah we're
having an experience
we've already gone into the the idea
that time is how we perceive this thing
yeah talk about mushrooms that mushroom
chip we weren't together but we were
together yeah at the same Festival the
epiphany epiphany I had was it's it's
one thinging itself meaning the noun is
the verb and the subject it's all just
kind of collapsing in on it that doesn't
mean
just to let you know that I'm not taking
it to the place of like so there's a God
who's poking and tweaking and judging
and he's mad when you masturbate or
whatever but there does seem to be like
a mystery that's kind of undulating as I
always say do you have any perspective
or feeling about that I mean we haven't
talked about it in a long time
my daughter asked me recently because
some kid in kindergarten was like uh do
you believe in God like I asked her for
the first time and so she came home and
she's like do you believe in God and I
was like oh and first I was like where
did that come from and she's like Titus
wants to Titus asked me if I could even
try this and uh and I was like I do
believe in God
um and that was enough for her but I was
like ready with my answer for it you
know she's already off she's already off
okay but I was like I was like it it's
like I do come back to this thing it is
the the spirit that moves through all
things you know that is how what I I
don't believe in a persona vacation or
whatnot but I do believe that we are the
uh the U I think the universe itself is
the god that love is the god like there
is no God head I do not believe in a
godhead but I do believe in that that we
are we are here for a reason that is for
the universe to experience itself
um and that it's it's it's what a lovely
thing that we get to be conscious beings
what a what a treat
um because it's it they're they're just
the little blips and we get to be a
little blip yeah yeah that's interesting
any inkling that underneath who you
really are is the big blip that's a
leading question oh like a soul
well let's let's take what you just said
to its logical conclusion yeah and
that's a condescending one I don't mean
that to be condescending I'm like let's
explore it yeah meaning a lot of people
feel that way not a lot but I feel that
way too yeah and when I look at it it's
like
okay if we're light bulbs and God is the
electricity
then the the animating principle
or you know in religious language the
the spring yeah so there's like a spring
of water that's keeping you that is your
awareness
if that's who you really are
when Kurt dies the light bulb breaks but
the electricity goes where electricity
always was and will always be right
the only reason I mention that is
because it's awfully helpful when
dealing with existential dread or
feelings of like
there has to be like a a releasing a
forgiving of Kurt and his life and his
and his fear of death and all that sort
of stuff yeah but an awareness go let's
go back to the ocean creates a glass of
water and when Kurt dies he gets poured
back into the ocean right but nothing
was added or taken away from the ocean
actually wave is a better example
because there's no glass it's just the
way it breaks there's Kurt and you're
also very much again in line with
particle physics that we are that
Consciousness is probably a a wave in
the state of breaking right yes
constantly in motion and then all of a
sudden it has it's done and you see it
the sizzle like that sizzle the pullback
sizzle yeah look feels like old people
to me the pullback sizzle you know yeah
yeah so I'm like that feels like the
golden years we're just kind of like oh
and but you kind of know you're going
back yeah that Vibes with you yes 100
however it still doesn't I don't know if
it necessarily qualms any fears because
of there is the the the fear of losing
identity you know the if the glass is
the identity of the individual the
container yeah the container of losing
that container because the container is
all you know yep
um or being conscious of it because I
think I don't think you're conscious uh
you know once we lose this Consciousness
well that's a great Thomas Merton who's
uh Trappist yeah I don't think that's a
Catholic trap this is not Catholic but
anyway he says I don't know much about
heaven but there won't be much of you
there to experience yes and I'm like
yeah 100 so that's why I think it's cake
and eat it too time meaning if you want
to tell me Pete dies and therefore Pete
should be all his peteness because it
goes away yes and then the fundamental
animating principle if he doesn't go
anywhere and that's really who I am
anyway yeah and by the way the fear is
something that I think about all the
time I'm like I think again that's
something we forgive like the song in
your head yeah you go like wouldn't it
be nice
to die in full Trust of like nothing's
happening anyway I'm not I had this have
you smoked five Meo DMT no okay that
that one I I I I don't want to say I
recommend it but that one I have did you
say five emiot five Meo DMT five meods
there's two dmts oh okay Buck Rogers is
nndmt okay and then there's toad smoking
toad Venom oh okay there's five Meo DMS
oh wow anyway that that feeling was a
death experience for me and it was very
much like you don't go anywhere in fact
all of the coming and going apparatus
which is an illusion is removed and you
stand naked where you always were oh
interesting meaning it's a journey to
know yeah like death is a journey of
zero steps and it it again I know this
was just a mystical experience but it
really told me
that it was like being a lobster like
lobster being pulled out of its shell
but really going nowhere was important
it wasn't like we're down or this yeah
it was like oh my God like it was it was
like a dropping of Illusion and a
homecoming and when I say there was no
me there but there was the the bigger me
uh-huh you know what I'm saying I'm
trying to give you your cake and eat it
too meaning yeah Kurt is gone but um
also everything that Kurt was made of is
there because everything is there yeah
and I do feel that
um
way as well in even in the sense of if
we're going back to I keep coming back
because I'm reading this book to like
the physics of it that each point in the
space-time Continuum exists it's just it
exists right and so there is a you know
my mom's exists currently you know like
we will always exist our former selves
exist it's all happening at once it is
all happening at once and time is
relative and separation is an illusion
separation is an illusion the other way
you could say it is none of it exists
meaning yes and I'd be like more of like
a Buddhist way it's the dream of God yes
God fella you could say God willingly
fell asleep to experience itself yeah or
there are other Traditions that say it's
more it's a little harsher it's like
it's my uh it's something to renounce
because you're there are all these
horrible things and it's like yeah snap
out of it this is what happens when you
think you're separate so stop kind of
stop thinking you're separate and come
home but it's it's it's different ways
of cutting the same cake yeah I think so
interesting Kurt because yeah
I mean I hate to be so transparent as to
say like when someone Vibes with the
things that I Vibe with I like it but
the reason I like it is because it's so
beautiful and peaceful and nice yeah and
uh
I don't know I think it might be the
point of life
you know what I'm saying yeah I always
say like I don't think you were going to
be sitting around old men and being like
remember
rafifi like I I if we are I think maybe
we we just missed a step
you know what I mean yeah no we're going
to be thinking about dying a lot I hope
well that's the Taoist thing if you find
your way in the morning you gladly go in
the evening I think that might be part
of the puzzle oh interesting I like that
all right
um did I cut you off at any point of
some of your time okay great
um in summation let me just check the
time oh this is perfect what a pro
what a pro
real quick the special is called
perfectly stupid it's not called trust
me it's called perfectly stupid and you
can get it at moment yeah you can get a
moment right now you just go to
perfectly stupid.com because it will
link to everywhere that you can get it
which by the way at any time whenever
you're listening to this perfectly
stupid.com something that's empty that's
also full is a great model for for the
universe according to a lot of different
Traditions yeah and physics yeah
like reality not being real
the chance of our eyes reporting reality
as it is is being zero all that sort of
stuff all of this is just this beautiful
almost like DNA double helix of like
here's these spiritual things and here's
these scientific things and it's just
one of the great joys of my life is to
see them come together yeah any who's a
woozle
um
check that out perfectly stupid.com can
you think of a time in your life when
you laughed really really hard and I
always like to take people off the hook
at this moment it doesn't have to be a
great story I'm not waiting for those I
mean I think last time yeah you asked me
this I think we talked about flying
squirrel loves it every time
[Laughter]
we talked about I think first time uh
man in it would think it's South by
Southwest 20 yeah I don't know 2012 or
something yeah but there was an onion
just it was just a picture with caption
it's just a picture of flying squirrel
it's just a flag squirrel loves it every
time flying squirrel loves it every time
it wasn't a story it was just it was
just the image there's no there's no
story can I tell you another one that I
love yeah
oh God cast members coming into the
audience
[Laughter]
they're breaking the fourth of all and
they like rubbed the head of a bald man
and stuff and it's just written from the
pure panic
and there also was another onion that
absolutely killed me which was
Christopher Walken writing an opinion
piece about how much he loved hot dogs
and it is the biggest I never read
something where like absurd yeah where
the joke was this is it yeah he's just
there were a couple lines that stick out
one was you don't even have to cook them
was one and then the last paragraph and
you have to read it in Christopher
Walken's voice and they know you will
yeah is like to reiterate I just want to
say how much I [__] love hot dogs and
I just I I just lost it in a Barnes
Noble in Maine I remember where I was
isn't that nice it's true yeah truly
I I I love that that's your answer again
Kurt thanks man thank you so much this
was a day off yeah for old homsy thank
you thank you thank you thank you would
you say keep it crispy for us keep it
crispy no do it as one of your Bob's
Burgers characters keep it crispy pretty
happy pretty much use my voice me too by
the way what if that was my way of being
like because they're the same [__] you
Kirk now I just watched the one where
you're the bully steal her hat
um thanks man thank you
oh yeah
[Music]